I cook for warthogs EMU lions tigers
hyenas spoonbill Sunbear flamingos and
Jeff they can be very picky every
morning I'm preparing around 350 pounds
of food my name is Stacy Kyle's and I
prepare the food for the animals at the
Oakland Zoo I'm also known as physician
my day starts off very early before the
Sun even comes up I've got to get the
food for the animals or we have nothing
to prepare the calm before the storm of
getting to the market I need to get
about a ton of food today literally the
produce market is kind of hectic you've
got a lot of forklifts running back and
forth you've got trucks everywhere
there's a lot to choose from
I have to stay organized or this can get
very overwhelming I've got a huge market
that I've got to go through I've got to
pick out the right produce so I have a
limited amount of time at the market
because I have to get back here to
prepare the diets I open the door to the
kitchen and then I know my day has truly
begun
Sun bears 48 grams Apple Kawada Monday
three hard-boiled eggs lioness 10 bones
and miles of grapes 7 servings 60 grams
of cricket one dropper the vitamin 44
grandma the zoo itself as a whole
prepares about a thousand diets a day so
that's anywhere from the elephant's down
to the leaf-cutter ants and all the
little reptiles and the little frogs
it's important that we get the diets
right because the animals can't send the
food back they can't tell us oh I don't
like this
we don't take days off everything still
has to happen the food gets prepared
exactly the same way every single day I
tried telling those Christmas wants they
didn't pay attention